while the ending of Wonka Works
successfully as a conclusion to the
movie self-contained narrative it's
weird as an origin story for this
particular character whether you're
talking about the book or the two
previous movie adaptations willly Wonka
is a character famous for his
mysteriousness and reclusiveness the
Gene Wilder version in particular has a
sharp cynical Edge he doesn't even Fain
caring about kids getting injured on his
factory tour and even Charlie nearly
gets screwed out of his reward due to
the fine print and a contract he
couldn't possibly read if Wonker is all
about a younger Wonka learning the value
of friendship isn't it weird to think
he'd later go on to shut himself up in
his Factory and shun the outside world
perhaps the lumus would be friends
enough for him in his reclus years but
surely he'd want to stay in some contact
with noodle and his other human friends
as well right furthermore it's sad to
imagine this version of woner screwed
over by contract law and his youth
growing up to be the same man who would
try to do the same to other people